hey everybody enjoy this early look at
the opening of marvel's guardians of the
galaxy running in 4k on the xbox series
x you may have noticed at the top of the
screen there is a streaming mode
watermark that's because we needed to
turn license music off so we were able
to show the game without getting
approximately 10 billion copyright
strikes unfortunately this means the
watermark is present for the entirety of
the video as well as a few moments where
there might be a lack of music because
well the licensed music is turned off if
you enjoyed this video give us a like
and sub and stay tuned for our upcoming
review of marvel's guardians of the
galaxy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we'll bring hell down
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i wonder you can hear me
is that your new tape
star-lord
who's the guy with the scary eyes
he doesn't have a name he's one of the
space writers and he's not scary he's
cool
your space rider certainly got his hands
full
pretty far out
nobody says far out anymore mom
ma
nobody says far out anymore
oh well your mom does
maybe we should see if we could get
tickets to see them live really
your mom may not look it but i was quite
the rocker when i was your age
your father and i would just
lie on the hood of my old chevy and
listen to black sabbath you like black
sabbath
like i said your mom's cooler than you
think
oh we'd look up at the stars and he'd
tell me all about the places he'd been
mom how about some cake huh
yeah i'll be up in a sec
you said that 15 minutes ago
if you don't hurry i'm gonna eat that
whole cake myself no you wouldn't yes i
would you wouldn't i would hey watch the
hair
oh
peter
we've talked about you leaving your toys
on the floor it's not a toy it's an
action figure
more like an action landmine
stab your foot i will
he doesn't even
never mind
13 whole years
look at you
where does time go i'll be up in a sec i
promise
right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the final battle was awesome
looked like the heroes were done for but
they pulled it off
[Music]
oh man
traveling through space must be amazing
[Music]
[Applause]
oh man
i can't wait to play this
maybe i can convince andy to buy it with
his paper out money
[Music]
this will be worth hundreds of dollars
someday
[Applause]
i gotta beat janie's high score
this is embarrassing
three natural ones in a row last game
some barn i turned out to be
[Music]
it's pretty crazy that all the
destruction started from one little
mistake
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
need to build up my calluses
[Music]
keep hitting those dingers george he'll
make it in the hall of fame for sure
[Music]
[Applause]
might as well just peel the stickers off
and put him in the right spot
fingers are still crap from trying to
bookmark pages i know it's not how
you're supposed to play but i'm tired of
dying everywhere
[Music]
love to be able to ride one of those
light cycles
[Music]
i can't believe i caught this that
maiden show is awesome
[Music]
holy crap tracks
you gotta stop doing this man it's
weird
we were approaching the quarantine zone
how long was i out for 15
338 ticks
that's
very specific
the betrayer is ready to begin our
mission she has requested your presence
in the cockpit
gamora's on our side drax she is the
spawn of my sworn enemy a murderous and
a traitor
i do not trust her we'll try we're
supposed to be a team i make no promises
oh it ain't just a junkyard the
quarantine zones the biggest pile of
galactic war debris in the known
universe just think of all the tech we
can find
young group hey it's ah there you are
quill tell groot to stop worrying about
getting arrested
i'm not overconfident i'm just the right
level of confident
arrested for what
our ship just
accidentally slipped into the quarantine
zone oops our navigation malfunctioned
oops
how would we accidentally cross into the
nova corps force field
details
[Applause]
nice gizmos rocket i'm calling them
thumpers on account of the noise they
make assuming we get past the force
field and reach your coordinates in one
piece all we got to do is set them up
and these babies are going to draw out
our monster in no time
how's that even gonna work the thumper
goes beep beep beep beep and the
monsters come running yeah it goes more
like
hey holla rocket stop this ruckus at
once
and then the monster comes running out
of its hole are you sure about that hey
oh my intel came from your source
my sources are very reliable those
coordinates are 100 pointing towards a
rare elusive priceless creature with no
physical description to go by
what do you think elusive means it don't
matter what the monster looks like as
long as it's got ears you could be sure
my thumpers are gonna drive it right
into our arms
gamora up here peter
hey
that's my chair
oh
then why aren't you in it
i was uh
strategizing
it's one thing to get into the zone but
we still got to catch that monster
right
so did i miss anything
other than a ton of suspicious glares
from drax not really
now if you're done
strategizing
feel free to grab your seat we're almost
ready to go
okay here we go
rocket crew tracks get in here we're
going in
we still have a few ticks before the
next time window actually the next one
nova core security guard resets every
rotation we want to be in and out before
our code expires or we'll get stranded
wait for the next reset we'll get a full
rotation to do this nice
oh why is the nova net still up i
thought we were going in
well it appears the assassin's contacts
are as untrustworthy as the betrayer
herself oh please don't tell me gamora's
back door coats are bust we nearly went
broke getting them
relax rocket we still got a few ticks
before the next time window
the network just reset
you can enter the sequence peter
zero four five one
that's it four digits suspicious these
security measures are too simplistic for
nova core
it's not that simple the code only works
on this date for this ship oh
i get it gamora's codes are more like an
encryption key of some sort designed to
integrate temporal coordinates and our
ship's hard-coded serial into a local
number generator info gets in digits
come out
four of them
and
we're in incredible
i don't realize there was so much stuff
left after the war
restraint wasn't very popular in the
chitauri army especially with thanos in
charge
yeah it's probably all harmless now i
mean novacore had 12 years to get rid of
the heavy-duty explosives right
that's why i like you quilt you're so
pure oh
the wonderful and terrible things i
could do with all this
stay focused we did not come here to
scavenge why not the milano's weapon
systems could use an overall plus
there's good money in it
the peace that we seek is far more
valuable to the monster queen of sucked
off night than any illegally acquired
salvage
whoa
place is really shifty
i'm not seeing a monster but that big
cylinder up ahead looks like mining ship
peter's friend set to look for
friend
or a knight
and you'll see the monster soon as we
place rockets monster summoning thingies
flark yeah broke quell soda team rockets
up first
i still do not understand why i must
remain on board with the assassin oh
you're part of green team you assign me
to the team before you named it my skin
is not green
steel
teal
what
listen if we want to trick the monster
into going inside that mining rig we
need to place thumpers on both sides two
sides two teams and two clicks to the
drop side
grounds to escape
that's our cue let's go group
don't worry once the thumpers are placed
we'll meet in the middle and we'll
capture the monster together
very well
[Music]
bumper one done
[Music]
can you imagine
what the pink goop it's custom nanowrist
designed to keep all this war stuff from
floating away
just imagine what kind of blasters the
shitari had to use to wreck some of
these frigates
he is not a better shotgun
dangerous and unstable yeah yeah we got
it did not mean to do that smooth as
always quill
i'm not encouraging him i was being
sarcastic
we don't know what it looks like quill
neglected to get that info while he was
flirting on contraxia
i'm thinking that big cylinder thing is
our rendezvous yeah that's the mining
rig so weird seeing it all clustered
together like this
bits and pieces of a war that span the
entire galaxy held together by
pink goo abrian based nano resin
whatever i'm just saying it's a lot to
take in
oh look yellow and blue looks like an
old novacor frigate nice come on dude
people probably died on that ship
killjoy why do you even bring us here if
the place is so sacred
i can name at least a dozen planets with
monsters on them so don't know if you
notice rocket but people aren't exactly
falling over themselves to hire us oh i
have noticed if this job pans out sure
we'll get money but also a rich new
client we need to impress lady
hellbender with a monster she's
interested in not just any old critter
which is why we should have gone after
you almost made yourself a very late war
casualty
you know i like this this is fun
the three of us hanging out just like
when we started this gig before you know
who joined us
i do not hate everybody come on rocket
drax and gamora are valued additions to
the team you're only saying that cause
she's listening is that why your plan
has dragged tonight taking the ship
maybe
hey can a guy want to spend some quality
time with his friends
it is strange i have not encountered any
corpses in the wreckage
pretty sure that weighs a dead end
yeah you sure ah there we go pass this
way come on how can you even tell just
trust me all right hey group
you think we could find pieces of the
tryon shard in here
you never heard of the tryon chart
how'd you even know the other way was a
dead end because unlike you i have a
very keen sense of direction
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
take that brittle stuff
nice splatter hey 50 units says i can
clear more of these suckers than you as
if
whoa what the
rocket did you do that the scoreboard
you like it hacked it into your visor
cover last time you took a snooze
you hacked into my stuff considering how
many times i fixed the flarkin thing it
might as well be my stuff
optimal thump replacing distance should
be just up ahead
i'm thinking right in front through the
giant hole where this ship's cockpit
used to be
well that's grim
uh
try not to think about it it's better
not to wonder what happened to anyone
working on these old wrecks it was a
long time ago anyways
uh
ah
amazing i should have been recording
break over i want to see if he's alive
i don't know but he's twitching
larkin scott stayed quilt you okay down
there yep yeah i just uh
thought i saw a shortcut
right go ahead without me
i'll catch up
okay there's a crapped out novacore
missile bait just on the other side
we'll meet you there yellow and blue
missile big got it
i shot a thing i got it first tool in
the old toolbox
don't die don't die don't die
[Music]
oh hey little guys
[Music]
[Music]
you guys should have seen that it was
this weird lobby thing
not falling for this again
puffed another one
yo well you all right
it's so jiggly
[Music]
everything okay over there quill nearly
got himself eaten by a blob or something
squeal you must fight with dignity
or at least die with it not funny
uh well we got a lot riding on your gal
pal's mystery monster tip i hope she's
legit
like you could even tell if she had an
honest face
if we set up all these thumpers and no
monster shows we'll just need to salvage
what scrap we can and hold back with us
yeah scrubbing off all that nano resin
would take forever if it even comes off
just trust me
are you kidding me
that was too close you okay groot well
we're fine but we can't jump that you
don't gotta jump there's a sturdy
support beam on this side get groot to
grow a bridge across
just ask him nice life he does it for me
all the time
all right groot let's see that cool
that's one hell of a party trick big guy
gross more ship eaters ah they're
everywhere
all right back to business
boom right under your nose quill
gamora when are you gonna share your
contacts and sources or will you share
yours what you know about all my guys
only that you've got a guy that makes
the booms you've got a guy who can
reconstruct faces you've got a guy who
never says no
oh yeah i love that guy
hey greenies you see any blue and gold
ships out there you let us know
we have seen many such ships he means
active ones
we haven't talked about what to do if
you run into a nova port troll
we will restrain them until you're done
here bad idea those cops are all
connected through their stupid helmets
if you see cops you get my ship out of
here even if it means leaving us behind
uh flock that trust me i've dealt with
nova corps before even helped him cat
okay here we go
all right set her down right there
yep one to go
mark
no
no
flark and skagway
attacking batteries fry that's what's
wrong maybe you put it down too hard
let's just find a solution the
solution's a new battery with a charge
okay
we're on what's left of a ship
full of ship things got to be things
that power ship things around here right
yeah maybe you're going to want to use
an advisor for this you find a
replacement while i finish scraping the
fried wires
found something with a charge kind of
looks like a spacey car battery
okay
this thing isn't gonna zap me right
the chance is
minuscule at best you'll be fine
here you go that'll do nicely just let
me tinker a bit i'll have to do some
tweaking once i see how much juice this
thing puts out so uh watch my back
watch it from what
rocket help me scramble some critters no
no stop
just keep swaying those
you've got a point
[Music]
sorry to burst your
just keep these things away from me
easier said than done
don't feel bad buddy
we're all plugged in wow just in time
i'd like to see you fix it next time
come on two down two to go
brute's wondering if the reward's gonna
be worth all the risk we're taking for
this job
me and groot are nearly unkillable but
what if the rest of you don't make it
out alive guys this job is a huge deal
it's for the freaking monster queen of
sec narf 9. she does
doesn't know it yet
we pull this off and we're katie
hellbender's intergalactic monster
anglers
man
that thing is ridiculous
i think it was a ship or a robot
that's a pre-century a robot but it
would have been space worthy
that ain't even the biggest one they
designed at least five experimental
models twice that size how do you know
all this because they were my fellow
experiments back on half world
most of my parts came from the
cybernetics hanger next to the door so
uh
i got a sneak peek at all the new kill
bots
come and go for my uh
uh my cake
i didn't mean to open old wounds
most of them are just starving
i wasn't even a person to the worst of
the freeze mad scientist more like a
real smart walking gun
a very talkative gun
yeah
they tried to fix it a few times
the entire facility was the problem i
wish i'd gone back and blown it up
before the end of the war
yep that would have been a killing blow
not even close
groot need you to shoot a bridge right
into that eye socket
now i want to see you do that to
something in combat
wait
is that
yes i'm about to win this vet quilt
here goes nothing
we're inside a giant robot head and i
got robot parts inside my head you have
robot parts
[Applause]
hey bruce what do you think i should do
when i win this bet
i mean with the units still over once i
win
don't congratulate him
well i know what i'll be doing with my
winnings i'm saving up for our next stop
on contraxia to get one of those cerrone
massages
you're so predictable
you suck star todd
are you making fun of me i do not wish
to acquire hyper circuits
you know what quilt i think it's unfair
you got two guns i got one i think my
points should count double from now on
that's cheating
all right bumper goes there quill
it's not gonna piss off every critter
around right sorry quilt not taking no
chances after the last one i gotta test
it real quick
not again
i only flip the switch gotta love that
kill radius
[Music]
[Music]
easy for you to say you've got a pointy
stick
[Music]
shoot it very helpful thanks you're
welcome now stop distracting me
take this
is
[Music]
don't forget about that bumper
[Music]
rocket i know right what was that worth
five points oh come on you can't just
give yourself points like that
it looks like we're done installing our
thumpers
great job we'll meet you at the mining
ship
all right mining rig is right there
of course it's secure
as secure as a broke down shitari
shipwreck's ever gonna be